♪ ♪ ♪
- Guillaume et Stéfanie habitent
ce duplex depuis 2014.
Après trois ans de rénovations
majeures, ils peuvent enfin
profiter des petits bonheurs
de la vie. Mais le 6 août
dernier, une mauvaise surprise
les attendait à leur réveil.
GUILLAUME DE GRANDPRÉ
- La première qu'on a vue, ça a
été ça, ici. Ça s'est propagé
sur l'autre mur, ça s'est
répandu sur le mur mitoyen
au niveau de ma chambre.
- La sécherresse des derniers
mois a causé l'affaissement
d'une partie de la structure
de leur duplex.
STÉFANIE GAUTHIER
résidente de Tétreaultville
- Plus le temps passait, plus
on voyait des fissures tous les
jours apparaitre, tous les jours
en fait. Au mois d'août,
c'était constant.
SAMUEL DUMONT,
VP, Alerte Fissure
- C'est la folie présentement
avec la sécheresse des sols,
ça créé des situations qui sont
problématiques. Dans la région
métropoliatine, le sol est
argileux, il y a une urgence.
- Cette entreprise spécialisée
reçoit présentement trois fois
plus d'appels qu'en temps normal
concernant des problèmes
de fondation.
- L'ensemble de la région
métropolitaine est affectée,
c'est sûr qu'il y a des endroits
où c'est plus marqué, on fait
référence à l'est
de l'île de Montreal.
- Ici, il s'agit d'une
construction qui date
de 1959. Les travaux sont
majeurs tout comme les dégâts.
- Il faut comprendre que
l'affaissement, ce n'est pas
un problème qui est lié
nécessairement au batiment,
c'est lié au sol qu'il y a
en-dessous du batiment. Fait que
peu importe l'âge du batiment,
s'il y a une prédisposition
à avoir un affaissement,
ça va arriver.
- La plupart des assurances
ne couvrent pas ce type
de travaux. Les propriétaires
se retrouvent donc avec
une facture de plusieurs
milliers de dollars.
- Un bungalow de taille normale,
c'est des travaux qui peuvent
coûter entre 45 et 55 000 $.
- Et le coût de la matière
première ne cesse d'augmenter.
- L'acier, c'est sûr qu'il
représente une bonne proportion
du coût de contrat. Ça a doublé
depuis l'année passée.
- La ville de Montréal a mis sur
pied, en février, un programme
de subvention pour aider
les propriétaires à effectuer
des travaux de rénovation reliés
aux changements climatiques.
Ce programme a dû être fermé
en juillet dernier. La raison?
Il y a eu trop d'inscriptions.
En cinq mois, la ville a reçu
1102 demandes, ce qui représente
des subventions de plus
de 9 millions de dollars,
soit le double de ce qui était
initialement prévu.
- Guillaume et Stéfanie
ne savent pas s'ils pourront
bénéficier de ce programme.
Pour l'instant, ce sont leurs
économies qui payeront les
travaux, qui doivent commencer
en novembre.
- Pour vrai c'est un cauchemar,
c'est du stress psychologique,
tu le véhicules à travers
ton couple, à travers
ta famille, à ton travail.
Les répercussions sont énormes.
- Devant l'urgence de la
situation, ils ont rédigé une
pétition où ils interpellent les
élus municipaux à se prononcer
clairement sur cet enjeu,
qui risque d'être de plus
en plus fréquent.
- Le combat, il n'est pas pour
moi, mais il est pour l'ensemble
des citoyens rendu-là. Qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire? Quelles
seront vos mesures préventives
pour contrer l'assèchement des
sols?
- La Ville confirme que
le programme sera à nouveau
disponible, mais à compter
de jan